today on the matt wall show a horrifying
documentary on hbo intends to promote
the transing of children but instead it
accidentally shows why and how kids
really end up gender confused it's not
surprising but it is illuminating we'll
talk about that today also five
headlines including the governor of
maryland announcing that we don't have a
constitutional right to not wear a mask
we will deal with that bizarre and
alarming claim today and emperor cuomo
has a message for any police officers
who refuse to enforce his royal edicts
plus our five headlines and much more
all in the way but first i want to tell
you about um our sponsors legacy box and
this is a great thing to to think about
as we get into the holidays could be a
perfect holiday gift
just a way to preserve those old family
memories um you know legacy boxes it's a
safe and affordable way to digitally
preserve all of your home movies photos
that are currently trapped on
dated formats like vhs or film uh with
everything going on this is a great way
to ensure the focus remains on your
family this holiday season because
that's what the holidays should still no
matter what we're told that's what the
holiday is still about family a legacy
box can help you discover what's on all
those tapes and films and then keep the
footage organized and safe for years to
come you want to make sure you preserve
it you know because technology has sort
of moved on and moved past some of these
older forms but all that stuff that's
just wasting away in a box right now
why not update it put it in a place
where it's accessible and safe and you
can have it forever with legacy box you
can reclaim all the priceless footage
you haven't been able to see in years
the service couldn't be simpler use
their kit to safely send the moments you
want preserved their team will create a
digital archive by hand and then you'll
receive your new copies stored on the
cloud or a thumb drive or dvd whatever
you want um along with all the original
media that you sent them and it's very
easy very safe
very safe i should say i've been through
this myself
and um i mean literally you're just
you're putting everything in a box
you're sending it to them
and tell them telling them what you want
them to do with it and they do it and
send it back
and it's it's something that if you
don't do it
um and you know years down the line that
old box of of pictures or tapes or
whatever is decayed or it's you know
water damage or something's happened to
it you're going to wish that you had
done it so this is the best deal of the
year you want to take advantage of it
they're offering 60 off uh if you go to
legacybox.com
should take advantage of this limited
time offer and get 60 off 60
this exclusive offer is not gonna last
long so order their kit now and send it
in whenever you're ready it's a sale to
remember go go to legacy box dot com
slash walsh and save sixty 60
while supplies last well on monday a
horrifying clip from a recently released
hbo documentary went viral
in the scene congregants at a unitarian
universalist church
are invited by the female pastor to
quote proclaim their identity publicly
as lesbian gay bisexual transgender
queer queer or questioning intersex
pansexual asexual or any category i've
left out unquote a mother then pulls her
young son four years old it turns out
onto the stage to announce that he's
really a girl
but the poor child has no interest in
being paraded around like his mother's
show pony so he hands the microphone
back
saying that he doesn't want to do it
the mother takes it upon herself to come
out on her son's behalf informing the
audience that her son phoenix
would quote like you to know that she's
a girl and she prefers she and her
pronouns
completing this apparently familiar
ritual the pastor hands the child a pink
flower
as the congregation repeats its creepy
affirmation in unison
uh quote may you be well safe and whole
we honor you exactly as you are
of course
that's the exact opposite of what
they're really doing
this isn't even the worst scene in hbo's
transhood documentary which is now
available on their streaming platform
the film follows four transgender
children over the course of five years
it's clearly meant to promote and
normalize the deranged sort of child
abuse just described but any rational
person who subjects themselves to the
film which i did but
i wouldn't recommend it
we'll come away with a number of
important insights that the filmmakers
did not intend
phoenix's case is i think especially
instructive before the forced coming out
party
we see the boy in a dress in a different
scene on a bed filled with lots of pink
and rainbow colored things
and he's being read a book called
jacob's new dress by his mother
here's that scene if you can stomach it
then we slid into a shiny yellow dress
while jacob wiggled into a sparkly pink
dress what are you wearing esteban
it's like a dress i made it dad brown
you can't go to school like that put on
some shorts and a shirt under that dress
thing mom said and hurry we're late for
school
you're never late for school right
because you're almost cold
let's get the sewing machine she said
finally jacob felt the air refill his
body he grinned mom smiled back there
are all sorts of ways to be a boy she
said right wait i'm going through them
and also carina
and i'm also wearing
you are wearing they are your clothes so
they are boy clothes
dad looked up on his butt yeah okay
there's a girl clothes
i am a girl boy next in an interview um
the mother molly tells us that phoenix
is quote gender expansive non-binary
gender non-conforming gender awesome
under the trans umbrella girl boy and
rainbow boy all of those things before
finally concluding that quote we don't
really have a good term
well i have a really good term it's
called boy
now for his part the father zach mostly
sits quietly a common theme in the film
which we'll return to in a moment but he
agrees that his son's gender is somehow
quote up in the air right now
eventually phoenix who never at any
point shows any strong desire to be a
girl and appears to be mostly confused
and bored with the whole thing is
nonetheless socially transitioned into
one but the years pass and phoenix
continues in the nasty habit of being a
boy despite his parents insisting
otherwise eventually they get divorced
another common theme and decide that
never mind actually their son is a boy
after all turns out
but the good news is that molly feels
better at the end because she's worked
through her issues and is starting a new
leaf
where we are not exactly told how her
son really feels about having his gender
switch back and forth
while his home life is ripped in two and
his parents give up on their marriage
his feelings and well-being appear to be
more of an afterthought amid his
mother's
psychodrama
shades of the phoenix story can be
easily detected in the other three trans
kid profiles there's jay age 12 when
filming begins
she's a girl
making the quote transition into a boy
her father doesn't appear to be in the
picture at all i don't think we see him
at all but her mother bryce is a lesbian
who eventually meets and marries a
defensive lineman from the local women's
football league
we're first introduced to jay when she's
being given her first hormone blocker
injection
before the onset of puberty later she
goes into surgery to have a blocker
implanted in her body
bryce the mother seems unsure even at
times distraught by all this
but she goes along with it and funds it
and facilitates it every step of the way
similar dynamic with lena 15 years old
to beginning the film
also just beginning the medical
transition in this case from boy to girl
we meet lena and his divorced father
mike
as the two are out bikini shopping for
the young man we learned that mike had
his hesitations about the transgender
thing when lena first announced his
gender confusion around the time of the
parents divorce nine years prior there's
that theme again
but has since learned to accept it and
now his sons or his
daughters ambition is to become a
victorious secret model and mike along
with his ex-wife accompanied lena to his
first modeling tryout
by the end of the film lena has decided
to take it all the way um going under
the surgeon's knife the surgeon is also
transgender to make his physical
transition permanent
and basically irreversible
the most disturbing story of all
is that of seven-year-old avery
he's a boy who according to his parents
is really deep down a girl
avery's mother debbie traipses the child
all around the country doing media
interviews attending marches rallies etc
the cameras catch the moments when
debbie informs avery that he'll be quote
writing a transaffirming children's book
and then going on a book tour against
his will he doesn't want to do it
and also when debbie tells avery that a
national geographic photographer will be
arriving shortly to take pictures for
the magazine's upcoming cover story on
gender
avery is visibly and audibly unhappy
with all of this
all throughout the entire
uh film he objects to
all of his mother's schemes and at one
point late in the film
upon hearing that he'll be forced to
attend yet another lgbt rally in dc
says that his life is ruined
and voices a level of exhaustion and
weariness that no child should ever
experience let me play that scene for
you now
we're going to washington d.c
and we're going to be moving to the
white house for central area to throw a
book in donald trump's face
no i don't think that we want to say
that no this one is time to thrive and
it's for people who work with lgbtq
youth we actually go and meet with our
senators some representatives
after we do that
we go and sit and sell some of avery's
books for a little while
avery
manners i just don't want to even have a
book
i've done too much in this world it's
ruined my life enough and now
everyone in this world is going to know
if i sell my book it's going to get on
the news like with along with me for
like the 50th time at this point
and it's just gonna make my life worse
a couple years ago you wanted people to
know
yeah i i did but now that was really
stupid silly mistake and now i don't
[Music]
yeah that's something
let's go back now
avery doesn't seem too invested in this
female persona
minus the long neon colored hair and the
overcompensating rainbow outfits that
his mother puts him in
he comes across like a relatively normal
young boy
debbie noticing this with some level of
alarm decides that avery is just a quote
tomboy trans girl
yes
that would be a boy who is a girl who
acts like a boy
as for avery's father
and his view of everything it's never
made entirely clear like the other
fathers in the film he's basically a
useless lump of nothingness floating
along with the tide while his wife
psychologically and physically destroys
his son in order to satisfy her own
unquenchable narcissism these men are
literally watching their sons be turned
into girls
and that's one of the ingredients that
is always present whenever a young boy
is forced to sacrifice his masculinity
in this way they always have fathers who
have already willingly sacrificed their
own that is a necessary ingredient
and that is one of the important lessons
the film doesn't want to teach us but
does anyway
there is no mystery to the transness of
avery phoenix lena or jay or any trans
child
in avery's case his mother has it would
seem very clearly imposed a trans
identity onto him munchausen syndrome by
proxy is a known mental illness where a
parent usually a mother pretends that
their child is sick or sometimes even
causes the child to be sick in order to
gain sympathy and attention for
themselves from the public
if the psychiatric industry was at all
honest and trustworthy debbie would be
diagnosed with this disorder and her
children removed from her care for their
own safety as it happens though as the
film clearly portrays
doctors and therapists are much more
likely to feed into this kind of mania
than to diagnose and treat it
that's the other piece of the puzzle
that removes any mystery from the trans
epidemic among children the entire
medical field with very rare exception
has bought into this radical left-wing
gender theory a gender-confused child
with a parent like debbie
stands no chance
he will find no help
no protection
from his pediatricians or his therapist
or his school
they're just going to send them off to
be drug mutilated and further abused
but not all trans kids have parents like
debbie
the other kids in transhood seem to have
mothers and fathers who are perhaps less
exploitative than they are confused and
competent and self-absorbed
all throughout the documentary
we constantly see
the parents turning to their kids
and asking them for direction
relying on their children to take the
lead
asking them what do you want to do how
are you feeling how do you identify
you tell us
putting it all on them on their
shoulders the burden of leadership
placing it on their five-year-old son's
shoulders
phoenix's dad gives the closest thing we
hear to a fatherly lecture in the whole
uh the whole film telling his
son-turned-daughter turned son
that it's okay that he was a girl before
and it's okay that he's a boy now and
it's okay if he's a girl later and
really it's all up to him
well gee thanks for the advice pop very
clarifying
like any other child phoenix desperately
needs direction and leadership and
clarity what he gets and said instead
are shrugging shoulders and his pathetic
hen pecked father's refusal to offer any
guidance of any kind whatsoever
so it's up to phoenix to figure out who
he is
what reality is
what anything is
his parents will provide nothing to the
child except food a bed a roof and a
bunch of pretty dresses should he decide
he wants to wear them
other than that
the boy's on his own
and that's how you end up with
transgender children of course the
documentary wants us to learn a
different lesson in the epilogue before
the credits roll
the last thing we're told
is that lena
right after waking up from his as they
call it in orwellian speak gender
affirmation surgery supposedly turned to
his mother and whispered i'm free
now i doubt whether he said that at all
but if he did
it was yet another expression of the
tragic confusion that has plagued this
kid since early childhood he is not free
now that he has rejected himself and his
own biological nature in a way that can
never really be undone
but that is another lesson he'll have to
learn on his own
with no help from his parents
and the sad thing is that when he does
like so many other kids
it'll be too late
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
before we get to our five headlines
you know it's it's it's really important
especially these days with all the
volatility and uncertainty out there to
hedge your investments with some gold
and you know you hear a lot about that
of course but the problem is it's
expensive to just go and buy gold and i
know maybe if you're like me and you
hear this oh well you buy gold and you
think well okay
sounds it sounds nice but uh but that's
expensive well acre they're going to
solve this problem for you this is
something new you know uh the the price
of gold is skyrocketing lately but uh
acre is gonna help you buy gold and
here's how it works they let you
subscribe to gold bars for as little as
30 bucks a month you pay each month and
once your gold stash reaches the price
of their gold bars they discreetly ship
acre gold to your house
this lets you invest in physical gold
while you know without coming out of
pocket all at once a lot of people
especially around the holidays and
everything and especially with
everything that's been happening all
year a lot of people don't have the
money for that so you could do it this
way acre keeps you updated on your gold
stash every month and it ships you uh
the gold once you reach the price
threshold with acre taking physical
delivery of your gold means it's safe
and it's going to be soundly in your
hands in no time
aker designs their gold in california
sources their gold from one of the
largest mints in switzerland acre
provides industry-first packaging that
looks and feels more expensive than
others and also um keep in mind acre
just recently introduced their new 100
per month subscription for their 5 gram
gold bar you want to take advantage of
this visit getacregold.com
walsh and start investing in physical
gold today make sure you go to this url
also because acres giving away a gold
bar to qualify for the giveaway tweet or
post why you should be the recipient and
mention at get underscore acre again
that's get acre gold dot com slash walsh
thank you for your goal two acre gold
for supporting the show okay uh number
one yesterday the governor of maryland
larry hogan articulated his argument uh
against people who don't wear their
masks like good boys and girls are
supposed to
and his argument is it's it's something
it really is listen to this
well it's it's sort of like saying i
have a constitutional right to drive
drunk
i have a constitutional right to not
wear a seat belt
or to yell fire in a crowded movie
theater
uh or to not follow the speed limit
uh it's you know we're talking about
a quarter of a million people dying
already you know more than you know the
the the korean war
the gulf war and vietnam were added
together
uh which part don't you understand
you wear the mask it's there's no
constitutional right to walk around
without a mask this is we did it in in
1918 i don't know why we can't do it now
okay so a couple things here first of
all he's doing that dumb thing where he
compares war deaths to disease deaths
and that is always dishonest and
misleading as as it's supposed to be uh
you could do that
to make any number sound scarier right
you could say the flu kills 10 times
more people in the year than did the
revolutionary war i mean you could
phrase it that way if you want to if
you're trying to make it sound scarier
and mislead um second
comparing not wearing a mask to driving
drunk is completely hysterical and
ridiculous
what would just just just try to factor
this what are the chances that you
while driving drunk would hurt or kill
someone including yourself
probably pretty high right i don't know
what the someone could probably look it
up what are the statistical chances you
get behind the wheel you're drunk
what's the percentage chance that you're
not going to make it home without
hurting or killing someone
pretty high and that's why you shouldn't
drive drunk
okay now what are the chances that you
while not showing any symptoms
will hurt or kill someone because you
didn't wear a mask
what are the percentage chances
if you think it's anything close to the
chance with drunk driving you're a
lunatic i mean it's not even in the same
statistical ballpark not the same city
not the same planets
so these are these are just
not comparable at all
um and if if you know once again if this
is what we're doing
and this is the attitude we're gonna
have
then um then we're gonna be wearing
masks forever
you know if not wearing a mask is really
akin to driving drunk
then we're gonna be wearing masks
forever it never ends there's no
limiting principle third though
um
he says we don't have the constitutional
right to not wear a mask
okay no
no governor
let me just explain how the constitution
works
because you're you know apparently as
you don't need to know that in order to
become a governor
um
that that's that's that's not it
the constitution
is not a comprehensive list of rights
that we have
so it's not like oh it doesn't listen to
the constitution therefore you don't
have the right to do it
because if that's the case then we have
very few rights
no
the the constitution
is a comprehensive list of the powers
and authorities that the government has
so it's the other way around if it's not
in the constitution then you as the
government don't have the authority to
do it so the question isn't
do we have the constitutional right to
not wear a mask it's does the government
have the constitutional authority to
force you to wear a mask and if you say
that it does then i could say where is
it in the constitution
i don't see it in there
we have
um
the government is supposed to have
all of the powers and authorities
outlined in the constitution
[Music]
and if it's not in there
then
they don't have the power of authority
this idea that what so so
it's so it's not even just that the
constitution is supposed according to
hogan the constitution is supposed to
list all the rights that we have but
even in the negative
if it doesn't say you that you don't
have the right to not do something then
you have to do it what
it's uh totally totally incomprehensible
and incoherent
uh number two biden has apparently
picked john kerry to be his climate czar
um yes john kerry will be the czar of
the climate
and you know this is good for john kerry
and you know good good to have him back
he is such an aggressively unimpressive
nothing of a man just an absolute waste
of space he has accomplished nothing
done nothing what has john kerry done in
his whole career of note
yet he hangs around and just keeps
getting appointed to stuff when
democrats are in charge this this is the
definition of the swamp
and it is far from drained by the way
um
this is kind of how it is you know that
that guy at every office or workplace
who is just mediocre and bad at his job
yet somehow hangs around forever and
never gets fired
i'm actually not sure who that guy is
here at these offices uh which means
it's probably me that's the thing if
you're looking every office has that guy
and if you if you can't identify that
guy when you look around at work it's
you you're the guy
um so maybe it's me here but i know you
know the worst example that i've ever
encountered was at a pizza place where i
worked as a teenager we had an assistant
manager who i'm not kidding
would sleep on the job you would go back
into the office
i don't even know why you need an office
at a pizza place but he had a little
office back there and during rush during
during like friday night pizza rush for
everyone's pizza fridays he would be
sleeping in the back
and i still i'm still salty about i
still haven't gotten over it 17 years
later
but somehow he kept his job
never got fired no matter what he just
hung around
and the point is dc is populated almost
exclusively with these kinds of people
all of dc just nothing but the guy who's
bad at his job but never gets fired it's
just nothing but
my pizza place assistant manager
sleeping in the back that's all it is
john kerry the perfect example of that
and now he gets to be the climate czar
which is nice
i was kind of hoping to be the czar of
the climate though but um
i can still hold out to be appointed
lord of the sun i'm still hoping for
that position
he's our of the climate i could be lord
of the sun
uh someone else you know that's so
there's still a position uh you know uh
king of the seven seas
that's sort of my backup my position my
safety school if you will all right
number three reading from the uh daily
wire
the administration of democratic
governor tom wolf announced monday that
alcohol will be barred from being sold
at restaurants in bars in pennsylvania
from wednesday evening until
thanksgiving morning
an apparent edict intended to slow the
spread of the china-originated novel
virus
um
according to this is a the dr rachel l
levine the secretary of health for the
commonwealth on wednesday november 25th
restaurants and bars are ordered to
suspend alcohol sales at 5 00 pm until 8
00 a.m on thursday november 26th
and i'm looking through here
yeah there's no reason given for this
they never
explain how this is going to make anyone
safer
just suspending alcohol sales for a few
hours the night before thanksgiving
another completely arbitrary pointless
thing
but
there's a pandemic which means the
government apparently could do whatever
it wants and come up with any rules it
wants without giving any reasons for
them number four governor cuomo
yesterday had a uh
a message for any police officers who
refused to enforce
his royal edicts and here is that
message listen
i believe that law enforcement
officer violates his or her
constitutional duty
i don't consider them a law enforcement
officer
because you don't have the right to pick
laws
that you think you will enforce
and you don't enforce laws that you
don't agree with
right
that's not a law enforcement officer
uh that's a dictator okay a couple of
issues here first law enforcement
officers have a moral duty
and a constitutional duty
a moral and constitutional duty
uh
and they may determine
that for example
arresting people for having 11 family
members over for thanksgiving violates
both their moral duty and the
constitutional duty and i would agree
with them that it does
refusing to enforce a quote law in that
case is what a legitimate law
enforcement officer would do they aren't
supposed to be drones or robots if a law
is invalid if it's unconstitutional if
it's oppressive if it's tyrannical
they should refuse to enforce it
also speaking of refusing to enforce
laws where was cuomo on the rioting and
looting
okay those those are those are good the
laws against rioting and looting those
are good laws those are laws you you
need in order to have a functioning
society
and those laws weren't being enforced
i don't remember governor cuomo speaking
out about that
number five finally this uh again from
the daily wire
another big controversy
this surrounding uh the issue of racist
lip balm so if you're keeping a
a list at home of all the things that
are racist
your chapstick
is now also racist just so you know
personal care company burts bees has
apologized over an allegedly offensive
ad featuring a black family
wearing the business's pajamas oh they
sell pajamas too okay not just so your
pajamas are also racist your pajamas and
your chapstick just so you know
outrage erupted online when an ad
appeared to feature four families
all the families in the ad included a
mother father and children except the
black family
where there was a mother with her two
children
people were upset that the ad was
apparently enforcing harmful stereotypes
about black people
um
now why did this happen burt's bees of
course issued a griveling apology we're
so so sorry for this we're sorry that
you were offended by the ad for
chapstick
i don't even know now this is uh
where did they see this was this was i
don't know if burt's bees tweeted the ad
or what
but my question is where how are you
even looking at a chapstick ad for long
enough
to notice anything supposedly offensive
about it
but they issued the uh the the the
groveling apology they said we are so
deeply sorry we have learned a lot this
year about impact and intent
our intent was never to promote an awful
stereotype about black families or to
inflict harm on anyone we understand
that even so there is an impact and this
image causes harm really in what way
it can just hum me a few bars there i
want to understand
in what way is someone harmed by the
chapstick advertisement or i'm sorry the
pajama advertisement from the chapstick
company
i want to know exactly
okay so there's a there's a process here
step one
burt's bees puts out a pajama
advertisement
step three
people are harmed what happens in step
two how do we what's the what how does
this translate into actual harm to real
living human beings
that's never explained either
um and uh they explained though they
said that uh what happened was they
invited a bunch of families to come and
and take pictures in their pajamas and
um everyone showed up but uh
but in this case the father of the black
family had to work
and uh he didn't want to take off work
to go shoot
to do a photo shoot for burt's bees in
his pajamas i don't blame him
you know i mean if my wife came to me
and said oh you know we got invited to
put our pajamas on and take a photo
shoot for a chapstick company i would
probably also say oh what is that
i was it i got to work
oh it's saturday at 5 00 a.m i still i
got to work i have a thing i forgot to
tell you so there's a thing i have to do
so the father couldn't make it for
whatever reason legitimate or not and um
and that's why they just decided to
shoot it anyway
perfectly valid excuse and reason
but yet they still apologized
see that's a birch b says well we we
learn about impact and intent
no if you don't have the inten if if
what you do
is completely innocuous and innocent and
you have zero intent
to cause any offense at all which of
course you have zero intent
you're putting an
ad for pajamas the idea that you
intended to make some sort of statement
about black families is ridiculous
so you have zero intent to to cause any
offense what you did was completely
innocuous
that means there should be zero
apology anyone who's offended it is
their problem
not yours you didn't do anything wrong
they misinterpreted it that's their
problem
but of course that's not the message
we're gonna get from burt's bees before
we get to our daily cancellation you
know it's it's it is our responsibility
and this is something we we talk about a
lot on this show and something that
we're all we're all worried about um
it's our responsibility as americans to
preserve this country and our culture
and we know all the many threats
cultural threats especially that are
trying to undermine what america is uh
now if you want to help preserve america
while we still can join amac that's the
association of mature american citizens
it's the fastest growing conservative
group in america i can't recommend it
enough joining amac gives you access to
money saving benefits cutting-edge news
and a great bi-monthly magazine
but more importantly amac fights for you
um look we know that a socialist storm
is brewing we know it could be coming up
in the years ahead if you care about our
future like i do then join amac today
over 2 million conservatives like you
and me have already joined amac um you
can stand with us by joining right now
just go to amac
dot us forward slash walsh that's amac
dot us forward slash walsh
um the benefits of amac memberships are
great but of course the cause is even
greater join today at amac dot u s
forward slash walsh one other thing to
mention before we get to the daily
cancellation thanksgiving is almost here
and um as we've been hearing about and
you know we are gonna be celebrating
thanksgiving but also black friday is
here too you gotta celebrate
thanksgiving in order to earn black
friday uh since last year's black friday
deal we've been consistently adding more
features and products to our membership
program we're really excited about all
the stuff we've got coming up for the
daily wire to name just a few things
we've added more exclusive readers past
content um our insider and above members
can now stream our content on apple tv
and roku which is exciting because of
all the new content we're adding um like
the michael knoll show will be going to
five days a week starting on friday
december 4th your account also comes
with custom badges that you can earn by
participating in daily wire events if
you're an all-access member you also get
to join our all-access live discussions
those are the daily live streams we do
with um with one of the hosts where we
talk directly to you in the audience and
we have sort of back and forth it's a
lot of fun you also get two leftist
tiers tumblers early access to our daily
wire merge and many other things we're
also continuing to add new features and
products like the entire prageru library
which is currently being added to the
website will be available very soon
content from candace owens who will be
launching a new show with us early next
year many other things so needless to
say we're excited about this year's deal
for black friday and uh you don't want
to miss it all right um
let's get to our daily cancellation
today for our daily cancellation we're
going to be canceling whatever the hell
this is watch
[Music]
okay actually i do sort of know what the
hell that is that's a performance at the
american music awards this weekend the
performer there is named megan the
stallion
two e's so i guess it is the megan v
stallion
and she's performing her new hit which
if you couldn't tell is called body
now miss stallion is
getting canceled this afternoon for two
reasons primarily the first is that this
was a music awards show live in person
with musical performances and everything
in california in the middle of a
pandemic that's supposedly so severe and
contagious that we're meant to cancel
our thanksgivings because of it so we
can't see our grandmothers over the
holidays but a bunch of rich brainless
drug addicts in the music industry can
still get together to pat each other on
the back for producing ugly
semi-coherent tripe and pouring the
sludge directly into the minds of our
impressionable children that's that's
how this is supposed to go
now you may tell me that they did it
safely and they took precautions and it
was fine well i don't doubt it okay
don't get me wrong just like i don't
doubt that going to walmart with 10 000
other shoppers the day after
thanksgiving as so many people will be
doing
is probably fine and safe
but if all of that can be done safely
then so can all the other things that
the government has banned or strongly
discouraged
if there is a way for megan d stallion
to get on stage with a bunch of dancers
and shake her butt while screaming
random obscenities without getting
infected or infecting anybody else then
i'm thinking there's probably a way for
you to have a turkey dinner without
getting infected or infecting anybody
else
though perhaps your turkey dinner will
have just as many obscenities i don't
know hopefully it doesn't involve as
much butt shaking though
also if the risk involved
in hosting the amas however severe or
mild that risk may be is worth it in
order so that a bunch of pop stars can
tell each other how talented they are
then i'd say thanksgiving is worth it so
that you can be with your families
and that's part of the reason why the
amas and meghan the stallion are
canceled the other part
is of course simply that and i have to
just mention this that um the song is
really extremely fantastically bad and
stupid
it sounds very much like something a
character would listen to in the movie
idiocracy
that song and songs like it are a dog
whistle to morons
only those with room temperature iqs can
hear whatever is supposed to be
appealing about it
now i understand that it's you know try
to complain about bad pop music but we
must reach our limits eventually at some
point
we must as a society say
this has gotten stupid enough and make
that our cut off
eventually right we have to just say
okay all right enough
if this isn't the cut off then what is i
mean listen to these lyrics here's the
lyrics
if shakespeare came back from the dead
and found out that this is what passes
for poetry in modern society he would
throw himself in front of a bus
the only thing i wonder when i read
lyrics like this is whether the quote
artist
actually wrote them down ahead of time
like i i wonder if and i always do
wonder this does she have you know
writing sessions where she thinks long
and hard and goes ah yes i have it
inspiration this is it and then starts
writing
body audi audi
hmm
adi adi
is that how it works actually i like to
imagine that she writes it in
calligraphy with ink and a quill pen
shall i compare thee to a summer's day
thou hath the finest body adiada
body adi body adi
the point is that the music is very dumb
even by the standards of dumb pop music
and i simply won't allow for stuff like
this to be popular i won't tolerate it i
won't permit it
you aren't allowed to like this
and you can't
if you do you are canceled
and megan the stallion is cancelled
and the amas
are also cancelled as they should have
been from the beginning
because these are all the same people
who lecture us and do the psas telling
us how dangerous the pandemic is
so they're all cancelled all right
that's it for us today thanks for
watching everybody thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling our technical
producer is austin stevens edited by
danny d'amico and our audio was mixed by
robin fenderson the matt walsh show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20.
if you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle well tune in to the
ben shapiro show we'll get a whole lot
of that and much more see you there